reasons all right we're going to
continue to monitor this news conference
out of Maine as The Manhunt continues
for a man uh accused of killing 18
people 18 dead 13 injured uh the
authorities there naming every single
victim and their ages saying more divers
will be looking again tomorrow uh they
have no specifics on his whereabout at
this moment um the shelter and place
order that was a big piece of news out
of there cuz this has drastically
changed lives all around uh Maine
shelter and place has been rescinded
although it is hunting season so they
are telling Hunters not to take to the
fields there um in some areas they're
going to have another news conference he
said 10:00 a.m. tomorrow with an update
unfortunately Jesse this person has not
been found yeah he either swallowed a
bullet or he's hiding in a cabin or he's
in Canada he's very well trained he's a
professional killer you can tell by his
posture and his
this guy is probably going to be I'd say
maybe a month in the woods remember
Rudolph remember he just basically
disappeared and then he got greedy and
was dumpster diving this guy is going to
probably run out of bullets because you
can only kill so many deer you can only
fish so many fish and it's just going to
be a waiting game but he knows the
terrain he knows all the Contours we
talked to people he knows where to hunt
and he probably goes north or west
because if you go south or east east
going to the ocean South you're
basically going deep into Massachusetts
so he's probably West and I think this
guy might be in a small cabin somewhere
maybe in a sniper position has the place
booby trapped he moves around at night
but the guys have all the toys out they
have the the heat seeking
sensory technology from the helicopters
so it's just going to be a waiting game
and there's a lot of variables the guy's
got a motorcycle he's got a jet ski he's
got a property here he he's got a he's
got a house they're I don't I don't want
to say anything about the main law
enforcement situation but these guys
only have 17 men in that district and so
they're bringing in the heavy artillery
from the south the guys from the south
in the FBI they don't know the terrain
either yeah so this guy could be out
there for a long time Le are still on
the trees this is really thick
Wilderness it's a vast area Herold that
they have been searching Robert card is
a suspect 40 years of age he is
considered armed and dangerous lifting
that shelter and place order that's a
critical decision right now I was found
that curious It's good to be back with
everybody I don't like to judge law
enforcement or their leadership during
during a man hunt uh I'm not there I'm
not a law enforcement professional but I
would have thought uh that we might have
gotten more about what might be the most
promising lead uh that they have that
they have uncovered that's been
presented to them how is the FBI and
even the Coast Guard if you believe that
the that the water and that the ocean
could be a part of this how are they
involved what questions are they asking
have they what resources have they
brought to bear especially since he
announced that they were lifting the
stay in shelter order um I think he said
that you could hunt in certain places
but not hunt in in certain places and I
would imagine because people be firing
guns they don't want them calling the
police if that the case but a point was
made around the table that maybe maybe
the hunters could be helpful in this
situation but I'm sure they've thought
long and hard about this I would love to
know are the Canadians how's the
Canadian government cooperating what
what has been the kind of communication
what can you share uh because I think
what one of the things that has to
happen in these instances you have to
you have to maintain public trust uh in
the public safety uh community's ability
to go about finding this killer uh I was
I was pleased to see that the faces
humanized this this what happened here U
uh but I got to tell you if I if I were
related to any one of those people in
that in those pictures uh I'd want to
know answers to the questions that I
laid out I just think about the fear
that this has invoked in so many school
children I mean schools and businesses
have been closed up to a 100 miles away
from where he carried out this some
crime yeah for good reason and children
are afraid I mean these are small towns
Sandra you know everybody knows
everybody else and so the kids are
afraid and as that individual that law
enforcement individual indicated that
it's up to the particular businesses and
the schools as to whether or not they
want to stay closed um but it's very
interesting right now it's not just a
small Police Department it's the FBI
it's the state police it's the US
Marshals who are very good at this it's
Al bortac who caught that prisoner who
escaped from the Pennsylvania prison but
I think what's most interesting about
this is the fact that he left a car near
a dock and so the question is whether or
not he actually got into the andr Skagen
River uh or whether that was just a
diversion look the truth is he's a
Sergeant First Class he's smart he may
be crazy but he's smart so the question
is if he's absolutely insane an insane
person doesn't know to run away he you
know an insane person doesn't have a
sense he's not related in time and space
and reality uh but if this guy is making
a run for it um he may end up getting
killed he may end up dying somehow but I
really think that he's made a decision
after planning this out to go on the run
I think like as Jesse said I think he's
going to Canada I think he can cross the
border you've got a lot of the tribal um
uh the the various Native American
Indian uh tribal agencies that might go
have to go through to get to Canada so
um and this note I don't know if it's a
suicide note I don't know if it's a note
to his son that says in the event that I
die or this is the reason I did it so
there's a lot going on and it could be
it could be that he killed himself I
don't think he did uh or that he's on
the Run well he's capable of a lot more
danger here the elite border unit to
your point has uh also joined the manh
hunt here some people who know him say
they believe that he is capable of
hiding for a long time you know it's all
speculation but it can't be informed
speculation I guess what I would point
to in that press conference that would
lead me towards the idea that he's
probably no longer alive that that would
be my speculation is that they they said
you could go hunting some 150 mil away
they limited the the woods restriction
to just those neighboring counties where
this initially took place so it doesn't
seem to suggest they're worried about
him being in the woods far west or far
north and Eric Rudolph is an interesting
analogy that's after the '96 Olympic
bombing but you know for a long time
they didn't even think it was him
they're busy pursuing Richard juwels so
he he could he could be off the radar
literally cuz they were not focusing on
him they're focused on this guy and it
reminds me a little more the analogy it
reminds me of is the hiker out in Utah
who killed his
girlfriend their names are escaping me
but he searched for him forever and then
find him dead in Florida right yeah Fair
Point uh the divers will be back into
that River judge that you just mentioned
uh tomorrow morning in another update
10: a.m. from authorities on the ground
there meanwhile up next Israeli forces
are on the ground in Gaza and the US is
striking back at Iranian proxies in
response to the growing number of
attacks on troops in Iraq and Syria hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else